good morning again sue this over since
your brilliant video on Friday I've been
thinking about Florence Foster Jenkins
her Wikipedia article has perhaps the
most damning first sentence I've ever
read Florence Foster Jenkins was an
American amateur operatic soprano who
was known and ridiculed for her lack of
rhythm pitch tone a buret pronunciation
of libretti and overall poor singing
ability but lest you think Wikipedia was
exaggerating I'm gonna play you some
Florence Foster Jenkins while I show off
how good I am at touching my toes that
was painful in more ways than one so he
Ford's Foster Jenkins began her singing
career when she was 44 years old she was
divorced her parents had died she'd
inherited some money and she decided to
pursue her dream of becoming a famous
opera singer and she had everything
going for she had the drive she at the
time she had the money she wasn't afraid
to fail there was just the one problem
with being a terrible terrible singer
and that's the crazy thing about foreign
Foster Jenkins she couldn't sing at all
but she really believed she could sing
she would come on stage wearing wings
and sing Verdi and it would be like a
total disaster except that she had fun
and everyone in the audience had fun so
she had this fairly successful career
and then in 1944 Florence Foster Jenkins
finally made it to Carnegie Hall she
played a sold-out show at Carnegie Hall
and she sucked and this is vinyl head
because Florence Foster Jenkins sent the
bar for worst-ever Carnegie Hall
performance solo that I believe we can
jump over it sewing to celebrate the
one-year anniversary of The Fault in Our
Stars Penguin has rented out Carnegie
Hall for us we're gonna have an evening
of awesome where we read and talk and
play music don't worry I won't sing and
all of my four favorite bands are going
to be there because of course my first
favorite band is the mountain goats my
second favorite band also the mountain
goats my third favorite band is you Hank
and my fourth favorite band is the
mountain goats and the mountain goats
are playing Carnegie Hall with us it's
gonna be awesome we're gonna do our best
to put on the greatest show that
Carnegie Hall has ever seen that's a
long we got Richard Pryor to compete
with Andy Kaufman Billie Holiday we are
gonna be better than Florence Foster
Jenkins so I guess you saw earlier with
my knees left I can't touch my toes I
can't even come close
as a result real
Stickley I'm probably never going to
live my dream of being a professional
contortionist but as you well know I
also can't sing and I am going to live
my dream of playing Carnegie Hall
Hank obviously in life you have to find
the places where your talents meet the
world's needs but the great lesson of
Florence Foster Jenkins life is that
aptitude is not destiny I mean Hank her
voice sounded like the mating endured
death squeals of alley cats but because
she refused to be self-conscious about
doing this thing that she sucked at
people responded they often responded by
laughing but they responded and it was
obviously fulfilling for her because she
sang for people professionally for like
40 years
it sucks not to be good at something you
love but I really admire people who do
it anyway like I admire myself when I go
to yoga class I think well I certainly
hope we don't replace Florence Foster
Jenkins as the worst Carnegie Hall
performance of all time I admire her too
as she once put a tank people may say I
can't sing but no one can ever say I
didn't sing some things you do for money
and some you do for fun but the things
you do for love are gonna come back to
you one by one Hank I'll see you on
Friday